a giant poster quoting a google
dictionary definition of the word woman
has been removed from a wall in
Liverpool the poster red woman women
noun adult human female but according to
one LGBTQ activist it qualified as hate
speech and was deemed dangerous for
transgender women I'm joined now from
Newcastle by dr. Adrian Harrop who
campaigned for the posters removal and
in our central London studio we can
speak to you Kelly J Keane menschell
founder of the women's rights
organization standing for women who were
behind the poster hello to both at dr.
Adrian Harrop to you first what is so
offensive about the dictionary
definition of women there is nothing
inherently offensive with the dictionary
definition of women that really isn't
what this was about at all this is about
what that particular poster presents in
that particular way in that particular
location represents and what the
underlying meaning and the thinking that
was driving putting up that poster the
underlying meaning then to anyone
looking at it was it any more than a
dictionary definition so that poster was
pulled by a campaign group that is led
by Miss Minchin who was led and
spearheaded a campaign against trans
people particularly against trans women
that's extended over several months now
mostly online but also in a real-life
environment where she sought to demonize
trans women and to highlight them as
dangerous sexual predators this poster
that was put up is a symbol of that
campaign it is that campaign made flesh
as it were and for transgender people
who are living and working in Liverpool
it is a reminder to them that they are
under such immense public scrutiny for
every single aspect of their identity
their behavior their body shape their
appearance and that campaign is led by
this woman Miskimmin Shaw aka Posey
Parker
that's the reason why taken down let's
get a response then from Kelly J at Kean
menschell this this was part of a
targeted transphobic campaign by you and
your organization well firstly I'd like
to remind mr. Harib that I'm married so
I'm mrs. Kim Minchin and secondly the
point of this campaign was simply to
highlight the absurdity that in 2018
saying woman equals adult human female
is an offensive thing to say and mr.
Heric delightfully has proven that point
by having a tantrum and contacting every
CEO or every executive on the board of
prime sight until it got removed this
wasn't a one-off though this wasn't just
a poster that you put up with the
definition of a woman on it and we
should say you're wearing that
definition on the t-shirt that you're
wearing today at Kelly Jay as well what
mr. Harrop is saying that this was part
of a long-running campaign by you and
your organization and as such it was
offensive how is the definition of woman
offensive ludicrous thing to say
Adrienne Harris really the definition
itself though is it Posey it's not about
that it's about the fact that you have
specifically Adrienne harem
mrs. Kingman shall I apologize miss dr.
harem thank you and you have explicitly
excluded trans women from your
definition of women exclude trans women
for the definition of woman female that
is not something that is what a woman is
mr. Harib woman dr. Harb thank you mrs.
kim inchul a woman is a person who
identifies as a woman an EU I did you
ask their identity before you treat them
absolutely not mrs. kim inchul and you
are fully aware of that is it I do not
what you and your misogynistic allies
seek to do is erase what it means to be
a woman in law and in life and that is
why this campaign has been absolutely
essential if you didn't push women to
the points that we are very very angry
that we feel we have to protect the
language around us by using words like
cervix have as menstruate 'as cervical
cancer obliterating the word woman not
even using it in campaign material we
wouldn't feel the need to assert the
fact that the meaning of woman is only
the definition is only adult human
female so I think the ball is in you
very much in your court what do you have
Kelly Jay came in shell against trans
women I don't I just don't think they're
women so I will counter that point
mrs. kim inchul by stating that you have
led a directly transphobic campaign that
has extended over several months where
your campaign is you have a misogynist
won over a period of months mrs. kim
inchul and you cannot deny that how many
women have you threatened to report to
their employers are you under guidance
at the moment because you call women
disgusting misogynist name was on
twitter that's not true at all mrs. B
mentioned on Twitter she didn't delete
Twitter and Kelly J at kim inchul about
your own twitter account which has
currently been suspended both your Posey
pinaka account and your human female
account you yourself were questioned by
police in West Yorkshire police after
activation yeah that you made towards a
Susie Greene the mother
of a 16 year old took a child to do and
elaborate on that accusation it was
because I said I thought it was wrong to
castrate a 16 year old child I'm asking
whether by using the language that
you're using that you're using
castration you are being deliberately
provocative
no I'm being deliberately truthful in an
age where it doesn't seem feasible that
people can just speak the truth well the
truth is most women are comfortable with
children trans women women and giving up
our rights to men Adrienne how can I
talk about em truth and freedom of
speech why did you want to see this
poster censored if you didn't agree with
it could you not have put up your own
alongside it I absolutely respect the
fact that mrs. keener and Childers have
a right to free speech what mrs. K
windchill does not have a right to do is
to make transgender people in Liverpool
feel unsafe and unwelcoming they're only
in the ethics yes with 30 and what
you're saying then I don't know if
anybody can help you it cannot be such
that the definition of woman the
dictionary definition of woman is
offensive do you know how offensive that
is to women mrs. K until no one is
objecting to the dictionary definition
this term has been appropriated by your
overall campaign makes transgender
people feel unsafe on a billboard makes
men feel unsafe it is the symbolism
behind the folks it's black and white
plain English truth that is the
symbolism the symbolism is that we knew
when we put the Billboard up that chaps
like yourself would think that they
could control what we think and what we
say we know this and that's why we did
it
it's it's absolutely time that women are
allowed to talked about ourselves our
spaces our rights and our legal rights
without men like you telling us that we
are not allowed to speak okay I'm gonna
have to wrap it up there Kelly Drake you
mentioned dr. Adrian tear up thank you
both very much indeed